the culture of censorship out there this
film shouldn't have been made is
designed to force everyone to live in
fear the progressive left fear of using
language fear of repercussions from
speaking freely fear of each other they
want a breakdown of societal norms
question of the day for those of you who
saw the film what did you think of the
Joker movie what do you think about the
media outrage more importantly is it
just clickbait do you think there's some
other reason for it also this is
something that I want to talk about
today have you taken the time to
contrast that the critics treatment of
Joker with that of their treatment of
the new Batwoman series let me know if
it's something that's actually kind of
occurred to you because it stuck out at
me like a like a sore thumb or a poorly
made probably made TV show so extremely
poorly let me give you some full
scrapyard the The Joker
they had it debuted this weekend we did
a film review for those who are not
members of Mudd Club behind the paywall
and ever since the trailer dropped just
a few months ago left us they've been
hysterical about claiming it should have
never been made because it has a white
male protagonist it'll inspire mass
shootings in case you missed it one of
those critics is George Mason University
film professor Mason's reasonable she
calls one of us remember and filmmaker
Todd Phillips decision to make such a
film irresponsible of the next mass
shootings in the country the childish
gambino similar to that of a joker we're
a traumatized society and you're really
going to throw in a blockbuster film a
film with professors with millions
hundreds of millions dollars behind it
I'm sorry but now it's not a commentary
and the cultural lexicon you don't get
away with it that easy first of all get
into this weapon all right no well how
second isn't your job as a professor to
articulate a counter-argument right now
okay I'm sorry but it's just I can't
even thank you PhD yeah it is romário
let you see from the left as they assume
that there's one person who can control
everything right you're just gonna
you're gonna do this movie when we're at
REM tight like there's one person going
hey so Trump's at sighs society let's
just release this film to screw with all
them the truth is people are individuals
different people make different movies
different people like different movies
this is the prob
seeing the entire world through the
prism of collectivism and we'll come
back to this the current the constant
through line that doesn't change with
both you see the Joker and that woman is
theirs and we've seen this with other
films we talked about it with tear down
the house knock down the walls whatever
it was in the house knock down the
hundred percent bring the rating along
with Citizen Kane on movie night huge
disparity between critic treatment and
the viewer reaction so let's start with
the fact that it broke box office
records ninety-six million at the box
office for people who didn't see the
film review we all gave it mugs up we
all like it
there's a caveat there I'm not sure that
it works on its own as a standalone
thriller and I think it's a little bit
of a trope to rely on the Batman world
anyway but it's it's a film worth seeing
certainly a masterclass in acting and in
filmmaking harkens back my good movies I
don't think you can take that away from
me so a couple of couple of points here
the media hysteria okay the first
question I think is important to ask is
how did the press succeed in creating
this narrative of a mass shooting being
linked to the Joker movie yeah
and why would they want to do that in
the first place the why is important now
what they claim their logic is that a
movie about a guy who snaps and shoots
people that that would inspire people to
to do that in real life and this is the
kind of hysteria and I've seen
Republicans do this as well there's no
basis in reality we can go back to to
tipper gore right we're rap albums the
idea that video games cause violence
research repeatedly shows us that there
is no evidence that violent media like
movies or video games inspire real-world
violence back then Republicans were
trying so well don't blame guns blame
the movies I'm saying with don't blame
guns don't blame the movies that is not
neither one is the reason that people
commit mass shootings second reason for
the hysteria I would say is a fake news
narrative as soon as the trailer for The
Joker dropped the blue check barked
verified Twitter world yeah they were
going around you guys were this claiming
that this would be a repeat of the
aurorus yeah in a case you've forgotten
that they they were claiming that the
Aurora shooter had been inspired by the
Joker and dressed as yeah that's not
true those claims wrong they have no the
wrong wrong the shooter wasn't dressed
like the Joker and he wasn't inspired by
him who dyed his hair red because his
friend had dyed his hair blue and
jokerz here is green and by the way only
target is dark tonight if this was a
blockbuster film he knew the theater
would be packed so let's keep this in
mind it's based on the idea that this
could be a repeat attack of an attack
that never actually occurred how they
claimed that had been carried out it
wasn't a guy who was inspired by the
Joker or or or dressed like him but the
narrative that they want to continue
with Tennessee where our shooting they
actually they use this so effectively it
spooked people so much that law
enforcement actually increased security
at some of these film locations
counterterrorism cops with automatic
weapons flank the entrance to the
theater at glitzy Lincoln Center yep
fans been launch it and had their bags
searched the egg was lying the block the
police presence will continue here and
across the nation some officers will
work undercover authorities say there
are no credible threats but many are
wary because what I see that Brigade
come down the street I think credible
nah Hugh be the judge here no credible
threats according to authorities what
does that tell you it tells you that
rather than focus rather than be able to
focus on doing their job which is to
keep us the people safe today's police
officers have to spend more and more of
their time and resources appeasing the
leftist mob just for the purpose of
optics right and that makes us all less
safe what do you think happens when you
have every single police officer in town
at the local multiplex for an act of
violence that's not going to happen
they've admitted it they're responding
to Rotten Tomatoes please yeah they're
not looking at the crime report or not
get in the CB radio they're gonna know
what's up at Metacritic today and what
is the leftist mob doing response they
point to the increased security which
they and they claim that there was
increased risk of danger from white
males in the first place you demanded
the increased security the police
officer said but there's no credible
threat they increase it any way to
appease you there you go see look look
at all these police officers you
shouldn't have made this film what Kim
Phoenix and you're a shitty rapper but
the media succeeded here in getting
people so so freaked out that they
actually turned it into a national story
when someone was cheering at the movies
I'm from ABC like someone cheered at the
film that was the closest
to a threat my god let me be really
clear here the only plastic man the only
person responsible for mass shooting is
this shooter okay murderers yes gonna be
held accountable as murderers yes
however if heaven forbid a mass shooting
does occur at this point wouldn't the
media itself be more at fault than the
film if their hysteria is predicated on
the idea that films might glorify mass
murders through giving mass murderers
attention isn't the worst thing that
they could do create hysteria and give
them attention yeah but beforehand by
the way there hasn't even been a murder
there's been a murder you if like the
Minority Report a fake news by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot please do sign up a lot
of credit calm / month level you get way
more content and it's what keeps this
this content continuing on YouTube for
all of you freeloaders so here's another
thing that surrounded these
controversies we love you still identity
politics right common complaint of many
of the the critics I don't wanna say
reviewers not the people in a film is
too sympathetic to white man open this
came from Rolling Stone I think CNN even
went as far as I said that the entire
movie is based on racism did they watch
the film well this is what they were
apparently they wrote that the Joker
snaps in reaction to being quote
oppressed by people of color and goes
well the movie draws from the same well
of resentment that trumps strums with
his racist rhetoric at his rallies the
fear of no longer being at the center of
the political social and cultural
universe with everyone who isn't you
positioned at perceived edges yeah I'm
more and more convinced that these
people never actually saw the movie
because okay spoiler alert spoiler alert
alright The Joker kills exclusively
white people no they were really trying
to make sure that the melanin and the
skin was directly correlated with the
severity of the murder
so let's look that would be race
contrast this with the EC I'm not gonna
say some CW it's like it's like dead
naming I'm gonna dead named CW the WB
series woman for contrast also debuted
last week been praised for having the
first openly lesbian superhero lead boy
in fact most of the reviews cite this as
a point in its favor I don't I don't I
don't know why that I if you're just
talking about plot points right like oh
by the way this she happens to be a
lesbian but this is
makes this show so important tumblr is
the superhero
munches carpet they even got MSNBC's
Rachel Maddow speaking which to play a
recurring character so you know it's
good so Rachel Maddow there as a
recurring character
the broad basically has a lesbian
utility belt okay this is the bet woman
yeah it's interesting to look at the
media's reaction to between the take on
the babe remember the Chappelle's
special we've talked it was panned by
critics the public loved it and then you
had Hannah Gatsby the feminist comedy
special er self-deprecation is
self-humiliation so this official will
not be funny that's what I look for
watching these things right right we
have a similar phenomenon here with the
Joker and bat woman let's compare it you
look at the critic score of Joker versus
the audience score and that's not huge
69 to 90 but then you look at bat woman
71 from the tomato meter and 10% from
the audience
this isn't an appeal to populous fallacy
here like I get that the fact that most
people like something or just like
something doesn't mean it's good or bad
but when consistently the 100% rated on
Rotten Tomatoes films are not liked by
the audience yeah and consistently
content that by the way by every
measurable ometer that you have is
artistic has merit the audience enjoys
and the critics hate when it's all the
time you do have to ask yourself a
question why why have we gotten to a
point where the people who are in charge
the gatekeepers of trying to control
what we think about meteor about content
why are they so far off the beam in
relation to their audience who they're
supposed to serve right now exactly
before before the pilot even aired Ruby
Rose and I had to look her up
Rubirosa who's that because I was still
thinking about Citizen Kane as rosebud
that's got confused the stories just
sort of meshed together still in green
and but then I realized no wait hon a
second one is from Citizen Kane once
from a WB show yes now I can file it and
I mental cabin got it this this thing
Batwoman
is geared up I mean is it is t-ball yeah
for people to like it how do I know
lesbians and spandex like guys should be
rating this off the chart
that's the 10% and they still hate it
you can't make money and vie
I don't know how you just think it's
like like some guy who sells crack and
he has a leg up he's the only game in
town I don't know I guess there's no
more market for crack bags here anyway
Ruby Rose she was saying beforehand that
anyone who didn't like the series was an
old white man this is an interview
Glamour quoting her directly some people
might not see themselves on the screen
and therefore not see the point but
there's obviously plenty of shows for
people like that there's plenty of shows
for white old men hey whoa angry butch
Morgan Freeman would like a minute okay
so with Sidney Poitier Audrey Hepburn
helped pat pat morita
mr. Miyagi I prefer my sensei's to be
named Patrick you're just having me wax
your car I've never done karate I know
you shouldn't pee-pee the point is
people of all stripes and colors they've
been leading men leading women in films
for a long time we don't need you and
this is why it's so corrosive to the
American fare it's this divide and
conquer we don't need to I don't know
about any guy here you tell me if I'm
wrong your favorite film is Constantine
and I hate you for it yeah yeah you know
I guess Kenny was partially Asian
because I enjoy the movie prestige this
is a great movie yes we don't need to
see ourselves yeah in the performer in
the physical sense we just need to see
an element of our cells of the human
condition in the character if you're
lesbian superhero in spandex doesn't
have that don't blame white men blame
your angry Bulldog writers though really
blame their fathers who didn't hug them
do not blame a viewer for not wanting to
tune in to the Orvis promotional our
thinly veiled as superhero okay and then
this is a spoiler and other things they
talk about let's get into sort of mental
health issue yeah spoiler okay all right
I can do the comment section is that
enough time boiler
I don't spoil your muffs and go okay The
Joker goes out of his way to make sure
that people know he's not
okay he's very open in the film if they
haven't listened he explicitly says he
doesn't believe in anything
yeah his struggle is feeling alienated
from the world around and he's grappling
with with mental illness right which is
something that we should be talking
about a little bit more if anything
we're talking about sort of themes in
the film that the clown protesters in
the movie the people become followers
sick of fans of Joker they would
honestly seem far more like leftist and
I understand how some people could make
the argument that they're to be
perceived as anarchists but the fact of
the matter is these people wind up
protesting and spoiler and supporting
the Joker and rioting in the streets
they value the collective yeah over the
individual and they live to hate the
Wayne family in this film if for no
other reason than their wealth we don't
know about about debt is it what's the
name of that one basic [ __ ] white guy
name I always forget that like Bill at
the time I was grilling them Bob Brian
Salyers Brian Bruns you look like a
fight come on but these people they hate
the Wayne family just because of their
wealth in the Joker by the way this
whole film again if we want to study the
film and talk about the underlying
subject which is part of the design of
film we could argue that it portrays a
nihilism it portrays this sort of decay
of Western culture and that we've lost
our moral sort of through line here our
sense of judeo-christian morality and so
you end up with someone like the Joker
who feels alienated and has a god-shaped
hole you can make all kinds of arguments
the one that you can't make however is
that he was racially motivated and white
guy yeah so this whole thing is
ultimately about the left's push for
censorship there was an article as
reading today where they interviewed
members of the Academy and there was of
course a female member of the Academy
who said I don't want to censor art but
we have an important responsibility to
but understand that film can influence
culture and said I quote this movie
shouldn't have been made oh wow so
ultimately you don't want this case if
you're going to try and make if you're
gonna try to make a case for parallels
between the Joker and anyone in real
life it would have to be today's
progressive left particularly the media
the entertainment industry complex the
culture of censorship take bear with me
here the culture of censorship out there
this film shouldn't have been made is
designed to force everyone to live in
fear which is exactly what the Joker was
looking to accomplish chaos people to be
divided from one another the
we the the progressive left fear of
using language fear of repercussions
from speaking freely fear of each other
they want a breakdown of societal norms
they want to bring to fruition the chaos
of class warfare they cut let me give
you another that they constantly look
for a scapegoat instead of taking
responsibility let me talk about a mass
murder it's was it the guns was it the
video games was it the movie instead of
taking personal responsibility for the
person who committed the crime
many left us sir mentally ill I can go
through the parallels all day most of
all just like the fake narrative aspect
of the Joker for people who don't
spoiler alert spoiler alert in the end
you sort of find out that maybe the
whole thing was a fib maybe maybe the
Joker was making it up that maybe it
wasn't true it's just from sort of the
insane mind of the Joker Sartre so I
hope I gave you enough time so just like
this sort of fake narrative in the film
of the Joker this aspect of the film in
which you don't know whether you watched
an actual origin story or just a tall
tale told by a demented insane clown
with the media
similarly we just never know when
they're telling the truth you like this
video click one of these other videos
playing in a box up there and hit
subscribe or the notification bell if
you're already subscribed so you can
find out about our new non controversial
videos which don't ruffle any feathers
and of course are not a violation of
YouTube's algorithms everyone's welcome
here except oh I don't know if we are
but it's our channel not sure how that
works